these soaring temperatures this week our
sign that it's a good time to make sure
that your car is in shape to handle this
heat yeah from tires to batteries joe
moeller shows you what to do to make
sure
your car is good to go as the
temperatures rise we tend to see more
people pulled over on the side of the
road with car
trouble well as this intense heat wave
rolls in there are some things you can
do to prepare
to make sure you don't get stuck as the
temperatures go up so do the calls for
help on the road
tire pressure is important your tires
need to be at the suggested level as
lack of air can cause friction and heat
and blow a tire
make sure your tread is still at a good
level make sure your fluids are topped
off where they should be
sergio avila from aaa says another major
problem people run into
is the battery batteries do tend to fail
during the heat and what you can do
to protect yourself is to give your
battery a good shake and if it's loose
that's typically an indication that you
want to tighten that battery down
so vibration and heat play a big role in
batteries failing
according to ndot las vegas freeways see
nearly 80 million motorists a year and
summer is busy ndot's freeway service
patrol is ready to help those stranded
especially during the heat
you can report disabled motorists to
nevada highway patrol's non-emergency
number if you are going to be in your
car this week make sure you have water
with you not only to help you stay
hydrated but it can also help
cool down an overheated engine reporting
in las vegas joe mohler 8 news now